GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THE BATTLE BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND CALIFORNIA
ESCALATING AGAIN OVER THE HEATED
SUBJECT OF IMMIGRATION.
NOW THE STATE IS SUING THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER ITS
CONTROVERSIAL DECISION TO ADD A
QUESTION ABOUT CITIZENSHIP TO
THE 2020 CENSUS.
CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
FIRED UP EARLIER.
>> GIVEN THE WAY THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS ATTACKED
IMMIGRANTS, YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WOULD BE
AFRAID TO FILL OUT THE CENSUS
QUESTIONNAIRE.
THIS LATEST MOVE BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO THREATEN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT JUST A BAD
IDEA.
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW.
>> Jesse: POPULATION COUNTS
FOR THE CENSUS.
EVERYTHING FROM FEDERAL FUNDING
TO HOW MANY HOUSE SEATS ARE
ALLOCATED TO EACH STATE.
CRITICS FEAR THE CHANGE WILL
RESULT IN A SUBSTANTIAL
UNDERCOUNT.
HERE WAS THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE
MOVE TODAY.
>> THIS IS A QUESTION THAT'S
BEEN INCLUDED IN EVERY CENSUS
SINCE 1965 WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
2010.
WHEN IT WAS REMOVED.
WE HAVE CONTAINED THIS QUESTION
AS PROVIDED DATA THAT'S
NECESSARY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO PROTECT VOTERS.
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP US BETTER
COMPLY WITH THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROCESS.
AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN PART OF THE CENSUS FOR
DECADES.
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONGRESS FELT STRONGLY NEEDED TO
BE INCLUDED.
>> Jesse: THERE WAS A GREAT
LINE.
MICHELLE MALKIN SAID ONLY IN
AMERICA CAN YOU GET SUED FOR
ASKING WHO IS AN AMERICAN.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS THE
PROBLEM.
YOU ALMOST HAVE TO ASK FOR AN
APOLOGY TO THE COURT TO COME
INTO THE JUDGE, JUST TO ASK
SOMEONE'S TRUE NAME, IDENTITY.
THEY SAID NO, WE DON'T WANT TO
GIVE IT.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
WE ARE IN COURT.
WE ARE TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHO
YOU ARE, EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WITH, ANY PRIORS,
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WHETHER WE CAN
DETERMINE WHAT YOUR BAIL STATUS
SHOULD BE.
NO.
THEN YOU HAVE 16 DIFFERENT
NAMES.
NO ONE KNOWS WHO ANYBODY IS.
GOD FORBID IF YOU ASK TO
FINGERPRINT SOMEONE AND RUN THEM
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS SIMILAR.
THIS IS A LEGAL RIGHT YOU ARE
TRYING TO GET IN TERMS OF
WHETHER YOU ARE CITIZEN, WHETHER
YOUR STATUS IS VALID.
GREEN CARD, ARE YOU HERE AS A
LEGAL RESIDENT, ARE YOU HERE
ILLEGALLY?
CERTAIN BENEFITS DEPENDING ON
THE STATUS.
THERE ARE RULES AND LAWS IN
PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
ATTAIN CITIZENSHIP.
IS IT FAIR TO THOSE PEOPLE?
EVERYONE WHO CAME HERE AND
FOLLOW THE RULES AND THEN THOSE
THAT DON'T.
NOW YOU HAVE TO DO AN APOLOGY IF
YOU ASK FOR IT.
>> Jesse: JUAN, ARE THEY DOING
THIS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
PROTECT THE REDISTRICTING AND
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THEY
GET FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
>> Juan: NO, I THINK THEY DO
WANT THOSE THINGS BUT IT'S NOT
THE REASON.
>> Jesse: WHAT IS THE REAL
REASON?
>> Juan: I THINK IT COMES DOWN
TO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE.
THE REASON WE HAVE A CENSUS, THE
REASON WE ESTABLISHED A CENSUS,
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN
ACCURATE COUNT OF THE ENTIRE
AMERICAN POPULATION IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE WE WERE PROPERLY
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE HOUSE.
ALSO THAT WE HAD STATISTICS
ABOUT WHERE THERE WAS A NEED FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING PROJECTS.
THAT IT WAS PROPERLY
DISTRIBUTED.
THEY WANTED TO AVOID PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T FEEL THEY WERE BEING
REPRESENTED.
BUT LET ME ADD THIS IS ABOUT A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAD I THINK
HERE, IT SAYS IN MY NOTES, YOU
HAD 63% PARTICIPATION IN THE
CENSUS IN 2010.
IN THE 1970s, 75% OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
PARTICIPATED.
RIGHT NOW THE ESTIMATE IS THAT
IT'S GOING TO GO DOWN TO AROUND
50, 55% OF THE AMERICAN
POPULATION WILL PARTICIPATE.
THE OBJECTION APART, TO PICK UP
ON THE POINT, IT'S THAT THAT
TRUMP REELECTION CAMPAIGN HAS
SENT OUT A NOTICE TO ITS
FUND-RAISERS SAYING LET'S GET
BEHIND THIS.
WE WANT THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO STOP AND THINK
THEN, IS THIS ABOUT POLITICS?
THIS IS NOT ABOUT GETTING AN
ACCURATE COUNT.
>> Jesse: I WILL ASK THIS TO
GREG VAN.
IF THERE WERE A BUNCH OF
RUSSIANS HIDING OUT IN
CALIFORNIA, DON'T YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD WANT TO KNOW IF
THERE WERE ILLEGAL ALIEN
RUSSIANS.
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS ONLY FAVOR
ONE KIND OF ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
THEY ARE PICKING A FIGHT BECAUSE
IT'S PART OF A LARGER AGENDA TO
UNDERMINE THE TRUMP LAW AND
ORDER IDEOLOGY THAT ACTUALLY
WORKS.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER WAY OF
DOING IT.
HOW DARE THE CENSUS BUREAU
ACTUALLY TAKE A CENSUS?
GOD FORBID.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS, THE OTHER
THING THAT REALLY BUGS ME, THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF CALIFORNIA
SPENDING TAXPAYER MONEY TO
ASSIST NONCITIZENS RATHER THAN
THE CITIZENS THEMSELVES.
THEY WONDER WHY PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THE SERVICES.
THEY ASK ABOUT YOUR DATE OF
BIRTH WHICH IS AGEIST.
HOW DARE THEY DO THAT?
ETHNIC ORIGIN.
RACIST.
OCCUPATION.
THAT'S WORK-IST.
WHAT ABOUT MARITAL HISTORY?
THAT IS SINGLE-IST.
IT'S NOT A CENSUS.
IT'S NONSENSE.
YOU NEED DATA SO YOU HELP PEOPLE
YOU NEED DATA SO YOU HELP PEOPL
PEOPLE.
THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU UNDERMINE
THE SYSTEM BECAUSE OF SOME KIND
OF SYMBOLIC IDEOLOGY, YOU ARE
GOING TO END UP WITH ECONOMIC
CHAOS.
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE
THERE.
>> Jesse: IF YOU WERE AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AND TAKING THE
CENSUS, DANA, WOULD YOU BE
SCARED TO CHECK THE BOX "I AM
HERE ILLEGALLY."
>> Dana: YOU ARE SCARED OF
MASS DEPORTATION.
IN THE 1950s, THERE WAS A MASS
DEPORTATION IN THE EISENHOWER
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK IT'S PROBABLY WHY THIS
QUESTION WAS TAKEN OFF LATER.
I'M NOT AGAINST THIS QUESTION
BEING ASKED.
THE CENSUS IS TO ALLOCATE SEATS
IN CONGRESS AND RESOURCES FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU ARE NOT HERE LEGALLY, YOU
DO NOT HAVE REPRESENTATION IN
CONGRESS.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THE
STATES HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IS
THAT, IMAGINE YOU ARE CALIFORNIA
AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A HIGH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT PROBLEM IN
YOUR STATE.
MAYBE YOU DON'T THINK IT'S A
PROBLEM.
BUT THERE'S NO UNDERCOUNT.
NOW YOU ARE WITHOUT NOT JUST
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS BUT
RESOURCES.
THAT BECOMES A PROBLEM.
THEN HE GETS BACK TO GREG WAS
SAYING.
THEN YOU'RE BASICALLY USING
FEDERAL TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO TRY
TO PAY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THAT IS THE RUB.
I DO THINK THEY PROBABLY COULD
HAVE HELD OFF ON THE POLITICAL
NOTIFICATIONS.
I THINK THEY ARE ON SOLID GROUND
LEGALLY.
ON THE POLICY POINT.
THEY ARE SAYING WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ENFORCE THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT APPROPRIATELY.
FINE.
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
YOU CAN DO THE FUND-RAISING
LATER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT ON THE
SAME DAY.
>> Jesse: AND THE SANCTUARY
PUSH WE ARE SEEING IN
CALIFORNIA.
A BUNCH OF CITIES IN
ORANGE COUNTY ARE SAYING ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH.
WE HAD THE MAYOR OF LOS ALAMITOS
WHO CAME OUT AND IS TRYING TO
SUE THE STATE TO MAKE SURE HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO ALONG WITH
THEIR SANCTUARY POLICY.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A GROWING
MOVEMENT, ESPECIALLY IN ORANGE
POLICY, TO FIGHT CALIFORNIA'S
SANCTUARY STATUS.
>> Kimberly: SAYING THAT YOU
DO NOT REPRESENT THE REST OF OUR
CITIZENS.
YOU HAVE MUNICIPALITIES STANDING
UP TO ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS.
I LOVE THIS PART OF GOVERNMENT.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE SAYING YOU ARE
NOT REPRESENTING MY INTEREST IN
YOU ARE DOING US A DISSERVICE
FINANCIALLY AND POLITICALLY AND
IDEOLOGICALLY.
THIS IS NOT WHERE WE STAND.
WE WANT TO ABIDE BY THE RULES
AND THE LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUPPORT
AND NOT ACT IN BLATANT DISREGARD
OF THE LAWS.
YOU SAW THIS EVOLVING OVER TIME.
IT WAS PERCOLATING IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW THIS PLAYS OUT THE ELECTION
COMING UP AS WELL BECAUSE THERE
ARE CERTAIN DISPARATE PARTS THAT
REALLY HAVE NO BID FOR THE REST
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE WAY THEY
ARE BEHAVING.
IT'S LIKE A VOCAL MINORITY
SPEAKING OUT UP AND AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO IN FACT WANT TO GO
OKAY, LET'S MAKE SURE WE ARE
GOING TO GET ALL OF OUR BENEFITS
AND NOT GET TOSSED OUT, CAST OUT
CALIFORNIA.
SECEDE FROM THE UNION, THE WHOLE
DEAL.
>> Jesse: THE SHERIFF IN
ORANGE COUNTY SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR TO
MARCH 19, THEY RELEASED 172
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL ALIENS OUT ONTO
THE STREETS OF THEIR COUNTY.
SOME ARE CONVICTED OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, THEFT, DUI
AND OTHER THREATS.
THEY ARE SAYING ENOUGH.
WHY ARE WE NOT PROTECTING THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTY?
THE JOB OF THE SHERIFF IS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE.
THEY WERE FORCED TO RELEASE
THESE CRIMINALS TO THE STREETS.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THEY
WERE FORCED.
>> Jesse: THEY HAD TO COMPLY
WITH CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY POLICY
WITH CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY POLIC
POLICY.
>> Juan: IF THEY HAVE A
RETAINER OR WARRANT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
ISSUE A WARRANT.
WE WANT THIS PERSON.
>> Jesse: WHEN THEY KNOW WHO
IS IN THE SYSTEM.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHO'S IN THE
SYSTEM, HOW ARE THEY WENT TO
ISSUE A DETAINER?
>> Juan: IF THEY KNOW AND THEY
ISSUE A DETAINER OR WARRANT,
THEN --
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT GETTING
THE INFORMATION.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT IN THE SHERIFFS AND THE
FOLKS IN ORANGE COUNTY HAVE A
RIGHT TO SAY WE DISAGREE WITH
THE STATE.
I AM ALL FOR IT.
>> Kimberly: I CAN TELL YOU
LIKED IT.
>> Juan: I DID.
I THINK IT'S THE CASE, AS THEY
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
SENSES, AND YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, FORMER DIRECTORS
OF THE U.S. CENSUS SAYING ROSS,
DON'T DO IT, WE DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS GOING TO UNDERMINE
THE QUALITY OF OUR SENSES.
SIX FORMER DIRECTORS FROM A
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC.
I THINK IT'S A WORTHY POINT.
>> Jesse: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT IT?
>> Greg: WE ARE A NATION OF
LAWS.
WE ARE NOT A NATION OF
SANCTUARY.
IT IS THE LAW THAT CREATES REAL
SANCTUARY, NOT SYMBOLIC
SANCTUARIES.
THIS METAPHOR EXPLAINS
EVERYTHING.
SANCTUARIES EXIST ON THE BACKS
OF OTHERS WHO DO THE RIGHT THING
OF OTHERS WHO DO THE RIGHT THIN
THING.
IT'S LIKE WHEN SOMEBODY STEALS
YOUR WI-FI.
SOMEBODY CAN ONLY STEAL YOUR
WI-FI IF YOU ACTUALLY ARE PAYING
FOR THE WI-FI.
THE THEFT ACTUALLY HURTS YOUR
SERVICE.
SANCTUARY CITIES ACTUALLY HURT
THE CITIES THEMSELVES BECAUSE
THEY ARE USING MORE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE, MORE SERVICES AND
MORE BENEFITS.
WHAT SANCTUARY CITIES ARE OUR
PEOPLE RIPPING YOU OFF OF YOUR
WI-FI.
THE PROBLEM IS THE LIBERALS
CAN'T SEE THE LOGIC.
LET'S BRING EVERYBODY IN.
LET EVERYBODY USE YOUR WI-FI
BECAUSE SOMEBODY ELSE IS PAYING
FOR IT.
OVER TIME, YOUR WI-FI CAN'T
HANDLE IT.
IT DRIVES ME NUTS THAT WE ALLOW
LEFTISTS TO BE IMMUNE TO THEIR
LAWLESSNESS.
>> Juan: I AM GOING TO TELL MY
CHILDREN WHAT YOU SAID.
THEY WILL USE MY PASSCODES FOR
VARIOUS THINGS.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A FEELING
SOMEONE IS RIPPING OFF YOUR
WI-FI.
>> Dana: YOU NEED TO NAME IT
SOMETHING LIKE CIA SURVEILLANCE.
I WOULD SAY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF CALIFORNIA IS PUTTING A LOT
OF RESOURCES BEHIND DOING
THAT -- THE TEXAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID THE SAME
THING DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
BECAUSE THEY PASSED THIS LAW IN
CALIFORNIA IN REGARDS TO THE
SANCTUARY STATE ISSUE, I THINK
THEY WOULD BE -- IT WOULD BE
GOOD IF THE TAXPAYERS OF